excusez moi monsieur je suis désolé mais
c'est vraiment très dangereux de fumer
près des pompes la station entière
pourrait prendre feu j'ai simplement eu
un petit problème et je sais que vous
n'y êtes pour rien mais je vais quand
même vous demander un peu de coopération
quand tout sera fini vous aurez une
histoire dengue a raconté qu'un train de
braquer c'est bien ça en fait nous on
n'a pas la clé du coffre fort je vais
chercher large
tu as besoin de combien la totalité
d'accord emmène moi je voudrais partir
avec toi
c'est vraiment une petite [ __ ] avec
une arme menaçant deux filles
prends ton argent et dégage d'ici comme
la petite [ __ ] cotec cet individu
était relativement douteux c'est à dire
ils étaient ils étaient tout toit fermé
la porte à clé vous savez vous posez vos
rares et ressembler à quoi melinda
[Musique]
je dédie d'abord dans les po net
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu diras la police quand
elle sera là
[Musique]
janvier aucune paix je ne pensais pas
que chez l'as far et tirer dessus c'est
parce que je voulais si je leur apporte
pas l'argent ils vont et je cite
m'attacher à l'arrière de leur moto et
me traîner sur la route jusqu'à ce qu'il
ne reste plus rien de mois
bon une sacrée première nuit
elle est complètement folle elle met à
couler le visage non non non
ah ah